[Music]
Dallas buyers club and everybody is
talking about this film it's an amazing
it's an amazing story
Matthew McConaughey playing a character
who's who has AIDS and he has for that
role he lost an incredible amount of
weight for this role you went through
your own transformation you play a
transsexual sure in the movie and I
think we have a photograph here of you
from the movie and I was curious like
when you went through this process and
you're excellent in the movie you do a
fantastic job when you first mentioned
that transformation and saw yourself as
a woman what was your reaction well it
was it was intense I mean I lost between
30 and 40 pounds was wearing high heels
every day and of course as you can see
tons of other things as well I waxed my
entire body my eyebrows included but it
was kind of nice it was a period piece
so I didn't have to do Brazilian you
know that's right it takes place in
let's 86 96 exactly a 70s Bush but you
know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so you had your whole body wax how did
it feel to become you know I mean that
must have you must have it was very
different I did feel very different and
I was in character the entire time that
we were shooting so I really got to live
in the skin of this beautiful creature
rayon and I really fell in love with her
I mean she's the most amazing person
full of life and charm and grace and and
also addicted to drugs and dying of AIDS
it's a it's an absolutely beautiful
story the did you find because you said
you were in character at the whole time
so you're walking around the set as a
woman did you feel that people treated
you differently oh yeah oh yeah I mean
it's interesting it's funny as I look
around the set and see some of the guys
working here it was always like the
biggest toughest guy who is the first to
offer his hand to me or Oh like they
opened doors for you yeah that's me to
dinner
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no what's that guy yeah hey bro yeah
exactly
Wow well you you actually we have I
think we have a picture of you you spent
some time with your mom as the character
that must have been a strange situation
we have a photo here of your mom and you
as the character it's funny because you
bear a resemblance to your mom I do it's
not crazy she's much more beautiful than
I have in the photo
obviously I was very thin and very sick
mm-hmm looking at that time I remember
there was there was one time I at the
end of the night you I was wearing
prosthetics cancer sores all over my
body
sometimes makeup would take eight hours
right or longer but there was one night
where I'd washed off the makeup and I I
thought I looked us I didn't do a very
good job I washed it again and then I
washed it again and I realized that was
me and I was starting to look you know
like like a wreck so it was a very
intense role and very challenging but
worth it the clip we're going to show
right now I believe this is a scene with
me talking to Jennifer that's who's
amazing an amazing doctor in the film
and let's take a look now I know that
you don't like to watch her so I've
actually never seen the film and I
haven't seen myself in the film and are
you uncomfortable watching it I was
actually a requested sleeping bag or a
small tent that I could climb into so I
didn't have to watch this right now
I put on my coat over your yeah can you
do that yeah I'm gonna do that this is
the first time ever in late-night mist
Oh
let's look at this clip from Dallas
buyers club let's check it out
do you like this address cuz I think the
necklines a little plunging rayon the
whole purpose of this study is to
determine if AZT is helping people come
on maybe you know there ain't no helping
it doesn't mean I'm gonna stop trying
[Music]
why you so good to me
bless your little heart
just promise me you'll show up to the
resolution I promise you that I will try
my very best
I want you to mean
[Applause]